Xbox one updates show no sign of
stopping we already knew that big
changes were coming to the friends list
and gamerscore leaderboards but now that
the newest update is available for
preview program members we know even
more xbox 360 fans are going to be
pretty happy with this update you'll
finally be able to directly download
backward compatible xbox 360 games onto
your xbox one considering you guys have
already spent over 30 million hours
playing 360 games on your current
console this update is a no brainer
additionally you'll be able to include
party chat in your twitch broadcasts and
speaking of party chat Microsoft has
expanded the chat size to 16 people so
if you always dreamt about broadcasting
16 different voices over twitch you
should be pretty stoked these are big
changes and that's not even all that's
coming with the new update it's
available now for preview program
members but it should be out for
everyone else soon and if you're keeping
track of all of Microsoft's big
announcements you're already in the
right place